a vala meu Deus como é que bota na
câmera aqui minha você mexer no celular
não que você quer abraçar com o estranho
é beleza Frangão agora consegui agora
consegui botar na câmera tira Olha a
fotinha para nesse botão Beleza agora
você tirar foto só que a pessoa demora
para focar é beleza Não beleza agora a
pessoa já sabe já botou na cama já sabe
ficar já são moleque bota o lugar que
tira foto já a beleza aí ó que a gente
já fica feliz a gente tá aqui abraçando
estranho ainda roupa estranho então não
sou sua amiga aqui tá beleza aí você
arruma um sorriso até que assim ó tem
alma sorrisinho inclina a cabeça para
ficar mais bonita assim ó assim ó e
chega no lugar aqui ó só que a
desgraçada da pessoa que tá tirando ela
vai esperar focar essa clica na tela não
fofocar não ela espera focar sozinho e
você fica aqui assim ó antes Tira Tira
foto aí e eu estranho aqui ainda para
você aqui ó
ai ai
pronto tirou extrema eu fiquei não sai
do lugar de novo a ela